MAGGIE JOHNSON:
The way that Google
started was an academic venture.
JEFF DEAN: How do you
find interesting problems
in the world?
ALFRED SPECTOR: Google
depends on academia.
So many of the good ideas
that we've brought forward
to the world come from academia.
JEFF DEAN: One of the real
reasons to engage with academia
is to get a really
fresh perspective.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We
empower academics
to work on real problems.
And in the other
direction, academics
bring ideas and
new approaches that
are put into practice
much more quickly
than in an academic environment.
JEFF DEAN: Oh,
that's interesting.
That's interesting.
All of a sudden,
you've knitted together
something that is really,
really, tremendously powerful.
MAGGIE JOHNSON: We need their
help because of the problem
we're trying to
solve internally.
ALFRED SPECTOR: Academia can
look far out into the future.
It can take greater risks and
look for really interesting
solutions that industry
sometimes cannot.
DAN RUSSELL: I'm Dan Russell.
And I'm a researcher for user
experience in the search group.
My job is to try to figure out
how people think-- particularly
about how search works,
but more generally I
work a lot with universities.
And that's my connection
here with the Olsons,
is part of the university
relationships program.
So I'm heavily
involved in making sure
that Google connects with the
academic research in the world
that's really relevant to us.
And that's how I know
you guys, ultimately.
GARY OLSON: I'm Gary Olson, a
faculty member at UC Irvine.
I got my Ph.D. at Stanford
in cognitive experimental
psychology.
Spent most of my career at
the University of Michigan,
as did Judy.
And I've been
studying collaboration
since the mid '80s.
JUDY OLSEN: And I'm Judy Olson.
And I have a very similar
background to Gary
in that I got my
Ph.D. not at Stanford,
but the University of Michigan
in cognitive psychology.
And then the tech world
grew up around us,
and there are lots of
interesting cognitive
things going on.
DAN RUSSELL: I think the first
that Judy and Gary were working
on was this collaboration piece.
And it became very clear
to me several years ago,
working at Google-- because
I've been here eight years now--
that the docs work
that were doing,
presentations and
spreadsheets and so on,
was really in need of
some deep thinking.
Now what I found interesting was
when I first visited you guys,
you had been working on ShrEdit
before that, the shared editing
stuff.
And that actually
really impressed me.
Because then years later, when
I was at CSCW, the Computer
Supported Cooperative
Work conference,
I was demoing one of the
first versions of Google Docs.
And I would demo this and
say, look, isn't this great?
And I remember somebody
coming up to me and saying,
isn't that just ShrEdit?
[LAUGHTER]
And that kind of reminded
me, gee, Judy and Gary
have been doing this forever.
And we really should
connect with them.
GARY OLSON: We did some
carefully-controlled studies
that showed that working with
this collaborative editor
really made collaborations
work better.
I mean, we compared
that with people just
using the white board and
paper and pencil and so on.
And the shared editor review
was a productivity enhancer.
So we had early evidence
from the early '90s
that this was a good idea.
And it took a long time
for it to be picked up
in the commercial world.
And so we're delighted
that it has been.
What's interesting is there's
a whole culture change that's
taken place in the
last-- I don't know,
25, 3o-- years about how much
more important teamwork is,
whether you're talking about
in an industrial setting,
or even in universities now.
Group projects in
schools of business,
schools of engineering,
schools of computer science
are just much more common
than they ever used to be.
I'm waiting for the first
collaborative dissertation,
because it's a natural outcome.
JUDY OLSEN: But there's also a
big science happening now too,
across universities.
And some of that is impossible
without these kinds of tools.
GARY OLSON: Working with other
people is considered cheating.
DAN RUSSELL: Yes, that's right.
GARY OLSON: Yet now we know
that it's actually important,
it's valuable.
DAN RUSSELL: The cycle time,
with which work gets done now
is very different.
I remember going to a talk where
a student presented his work,
and it was great.
And beside me, the
guy had downloaded
the data set and redone all
the essential key aspects
of his algorithm and came
up with a different answer.
So what happened was what took
four years, all of a sudden
now was compressed into
the time of the talk.
Think about what it would
have been previously.
Well, I'll get back
to you with the data,
and I'll reimplement it.
Maybe six months later
I'll write a paper
that rebuts what we found out.
All of a sudden now we've
switched from months
to an hour.
And that immediacy
of data sharing,
immediacy of being able
to reimplement and build
on top of the
infrastructures that we have.
GARY OLSON: Because
as we know, I
mean, to create the technology
that makes this possible also
creates interesting new social
issues about credit, sharing,
privacy, control.
So there's a whole
other round of research
that's got to be
done on what happens,
what are the
consequences once we
can do this stuff
technologically?
JUDY OLSEN: Every
time we give a talk,
there are excellent
questions that people
ask that all very much
influence our work,
the next things that
we're going to work on.
But also we find
out that people who
are experts in
various topics that we
find from the literature
are now at Google.
And so they're a
phone call away.
And they're willing
to talk to us, right,
because we're part
of this partnership.
And that's been
totally enlightening.
GARY OLSON: But in the
past, we did a sabbatical
at Microsoft Research-- I
don't know, 10, 15 years ago.
We did a sabbatical
at Xerox, PARC.
So we've done-- pretty
much all of our sabbaticals
have been in corporate settings.
And we have very strong
connections with IBM.
So we love to go back and forth
between academia and industry.
I think that's a really
important kind of partnership.
DAN RUSSELL: One of the things
that always impresses me
when Judy and Gary come to
town is that people come out
of the woodwork that
I never expected.
So for example, I think the
last time you were here,
people from quantitative
marketing came and spoke to us.
JUDY OLSEN: Yeah.
DAN RUSSELL: And it
was like, really?
I had no idea.
And it turns there was
this deep connection
that I don't think any
of us had anticipated.
And so there are
connections like that
that emerge that you
don't anticipate.
That's one of the beautiful
things about this.
GARY OLSON: There's
another odd connection
that Larry Page took a
class from Judy from he
was an undergraduate
at Michigan.
JUDY OLSEN: So I
take credit for a lot
of things of how
this company runs.
DAN RUSSELL: Nicely circular.
JUDY OLSEN: Yes,
nicely circular.
GARY OLSON: This is
just an ongoing story.
It doesn't end.
And I think that's the
nature of research.
So we'll study collaboration
for another 10 or 15 years
and we'll see where it goes.
But then other people
will pick it up,
and the story will evolve.
DAN RUSSELL: When we
started this relationship
with Judy and Gary, we had
hopes for certain things
that would come out of it.
But the thing that
most surprised
me was how many
things came out of it
that I hadn't anticipated.
And I think that's the key
idea about a lot of research.
You can go in there, you
can make your spreadsheet,
make your project plan.
You will execute X, Y,
and Z. And that's great.
It's the alpha, beta,
deltas beyond that
you don't anticipate.
and actually have
a lot of magic.
GARY OLSON: That's
one of the reasons why
it's been so fun to
work with you guys,
because we laid out a little
plan at the beginning.
And we've done some
of that, but we've
done so many other things
we didn't have in that plan.
And you were supportive
of doing that.
I think that was terrific.
JUDY OLSEN: It allowed
the inspiration came
from people reacting to
what we doing so far.
And so it's been a
really good interaction.
DAN RUSSELL: I think you
should watch their talk,
because it's brilliant.
There's no question about it.
Just watch it.